Welcome back to human emotion.
So when we think about emotions,
we know that they're inherently social,
they're a vital part of
our social relationships,
and they help bind us to other people.
So to what extent when
we think about emotions,
are we really thinking about emotions in
a social world and what is that social
world like?
And to what extent do our emotions play
a pivotal role in shaping the social
world that we live in?
So these are some of the questions we'll
be returning to today and our roadmap.
We'll be looking at the question
of emotions in a social world.
This is our second part of this broad
or a question of looking at emotions and
social contexts.
And we'll be having a very special guest
lecture today with a renowned expert on
this very topic.
What we'll be doing today is first
starting with a special guest lecture on
social emotions. I'm very pleased
today to have Dr. David Desteno,
a professor of psychology at northeastern
university who'll be speaking with us
today about this very puzzling but
incredibly exciting question of social
emotions.
So I'd like to welcome Dr. David Desteno
today as our special guest lecture.
So when I talk about social emotions,
I usually like to start talking a little,
a little,
a bit about the idea of character.
Character after all refers to
our morality, our reputation,
basically how we navigate
the social world.
And what I would like to suggest is that
our idea of character and primarily how
emotions fit into it needs
a little bit of updating.
Now the term character,
the origins of the term comes from a
word that referred to the marks that were
indelibly stamped in ancient Greek coins.
Once they were stamped, they were fixed.
Once you had your
character, that was it. Um,
the motif that we usually are familiar
with is one of an angel on one shoulder
and a devil on the other.
And as you grow up,
if you learn to listen to the good voice,
well everything will be wonderful.
Your life will be great,
you will be a virtuous person
and all be right with the world.
There's just one problem with that though.
And that's the data from everything
that we know from the past 15 years of
psychological science.
It's that human morality,
human social behavior just
doesn't work that way.
And so what I want to do is to
suggest to you that character,
morality, social behavior itself
is a much more dynamic process.
And a better metaphor really comes
from thinking of it as a scale,
a scale that's always in motion.
And where that scale is at any one moment
is going to determine what your social
behavior is going to be.
Now the correction I want to make is it
doesn't really make sense to think about
social behavior as the mind
having good and evil mechanisms.
Unless we're talking
about psychopathology,
it makes little sense to assume that the
mind would trave truly evil mechanisms.
What would they serve?
Rather,
what I want to argue is
that the size of this scale,
what determines our social behavior
are two classes of mechanisms that are
captured best buy a subs fable of the,
of the grant and the grant of
the ant and the grasshopper. Um,
and for those of you who don't remember
it, let me tell you quickly, um,
the story goes that the ads worked hard
all summer and toilets so that for the
long term it would have food
while the grasshopper wiled away.
It's days having a lot of fun and
enjoying itself in the moment.
And what I want to suggest to you is that
a lot of human social life is really a
battle between these two types
of mechanisms in our mind.
Now, one of the classic examples of
this comes from work by Walter Michelle,
what's in what's colloquially
known as the marshmallow studies.
And in many of you probably know
this, but for those who don't, let me,
let me tell you, I'm, Michelle
did a, did a wonderful, uh,
experiment where he would bring young
children in the lab and we'd put a
marshmallow down in front of them and
he would say, I have to go do something.
If you don't eat that when I come
back, you can have two, right?
Classic Longterm, short
term, short term trade off.
And what you would see if you ever
get a chance to watch these tapes I,
these videos, I encourage you to do it
because it's great. You'll see the kids,
they'll peek through their
hands at the marshmallow,
they'll lick around the table and you can
see them exerting a lot of effort. Um,
some of them to not eat them. And some
of them of course, gobbled them up.
And what Michelle found is that the
individuals who were able to wait to
forestall immediate cravings to engage
in self regulation longterm had wonderful
outcomes. They had better social outcomes,
they have better academic outcomes,
they are viewed as more loyal, more
intelligent, more trustworthy, et cetera.
And this idea has given rise to the
fact that we have two mines, right?
We have this older emotional
mind that cares about, uh,
donuts and sweets and sleep.
And we have this newer rational mind,
right? That cares about, uh, what's
good and what's right in the world.
And the way we come to think of that
is that the way to be a good person
socially is that if we can just tamp
down those crave and emotional responses,
that's where virtue comes from.
That's where being a good,
reliable partner in honest friend,
someone who perseveres for the longterm,
that's where it comes from.
And sure it can come from that.
But what I want to suggest to you is that
it's wrong to assume that all emotions
are craving and that all emotions are
there to focus on immediate results and
immediate desires in the short term.
I want to suggest to you that I'm both
the rational level and the emotional
level.
This battle between short term and Mecca
and longterm is being fought and social
emotions are a special class of emotions
that I think exist to push people
toward favoring longterm outcomes.
So the next few minutes,
what I want to do is give
you some examples of some
central findings of of this
and how we go about actually studying it.
So let me start with a basic question,
which is why do we cooperate?
Right?
Cooperation is fundamental
to lots of human endeavor.
But the problem with cooperation,
if there was always a risk, right?
If one person gets aid and then
doesn't help the other person. So if,
um, if, uh, June, uh, gives
me money that I can borrow,
if I don't pay June back,
I've done really well for myself,
but the problem is longterm
June's probably not going
to want to cooperate with
me anymore.
And so what makes me remember
that I have to do my end,
that I have to take costs.
It's also support the relationship
because true social bonds only work when
individuals can suppress short term
desires and engage in behaviors that long
term foster better social bonds.
And so what I want to suggest to you is
that one way we do this is a function of
the emotion gratitude.
So George has Emelda the sociologist is
known for saying gratitude is the moral
memory of mankind. It's what doesn't.
Let me forget that I owe you something,
even though in the moment I might want
to get away with not paying you back. Um,
Robert trevors who came up with the
idea for reciprocal altruism, um,
where we help other people because
longterm they're going to help us back.
That view's pretty well known.
What's less well known is that Trevor's
himself actually postulated that there
would be discrete emotional states that
would mediate these social behaviors.
And so what I want to give you an example
of is that gratitude can function as a
distinct emotion that mediates
social or economic reciprocity.
And I want to show you how it functions
to push people to favor longterm gains
over short ones and thereby
build social capital.
The problem of course is how do you
study these things? If I ask somebody,
are you going to be an honest person, a
fair person, are you going to cooperate?
Most people will say yes sometimes because
they know they won't in they're lying.
But more often because people are very
poor predictors of knowing what they're
going to do when hypothetical situation,
w two hypothetical situations.
So in real situations arise
and when push comes to shove,
that's what we can really see,
what role emotions are going to have.
And so in my experiment,
what we typically do our stage events.
So uh, in real time we can
evoke these emotional states.
So let me give you a quick example of
how we do that. Here we have always a,
a real subject and a person who is a
confederate that is a person who works for
us, but who the other subjects
believe is also a subject.
We have them come in and we have
them work on a task together.
The only purpose of this is just so that
they can get some experience working
together and when we ask them
later on the real subjects,
what did you think of the other person?
There's a context for doing it.
They didn't engage in along an onerous
task and the only thing you need to know
about that is they really don't
like doing it. And that's by design.
At the end of this task,
the computer is rigged so that it dies
and the poor subject is sitting knowing,
oh my goodness,
all my work has now gone away and
I'm going to have to do it again.
At that moment, the confederate comes
over and says, oh, what happened? Oh,
let me see if I can help you with that.
And through a set of
prearranged activities, she'll
go about fixing the computer,
at which point the computer comes back on.
And the subjects are always very grateful
for this because they don't want to
Redo that very tedious task.
And then we have them play
this economic game together.
And that's the economic game.
The point of that is it
really compares self-interest,
short term self interest versus
longterm communal interests.
And our sense is that would gratitude
should do is enhance your decisions toward
longterm gains towards communal outcomes.
And so the way the game works is
each person is given four tokens.
Each of my tokens is worth a dollar to
me and worth $2 if I give it to the other
person.
And so the best outcomes that you
can have realistically in terms of,
um,
uh,
selfish gain is not to give
anybody anything and to
get them to give you all of
theirs. And then you'll have
$12 and they'll have nothing.
The best communal outcome is for each
person to completely exchange everything
and then they'll have $8 each.
And so what you can see as long term,
it's better for me to not cheat June and
to exchange everything I have with her,
but short term I can gain on my
own if I don't give anything.
And so what happens?
Well,
in these experiments what we
have is a situation where um,
individuals,
their computer either breaks or it
doesn't and they feel gratitude where they
don't. And what you see here is
that the amount of tokens they give,
the more tokens you give,
the more communal that you're being,
the more fair you're being.
When you feel gratitude,
you actually give significantly
more tokens. Then when you don't,
now you might say, well
that's interesting, but
this person just helped me.
Maybe I'm doing it because I feel like I
owe this person and that would be fair.
So what we do is we also
run the experiment where
they now play the game with
someone they've never met before. So
yes, someone has just helped them,
but now they're going to play the game
with someone they've never met and to
whom they don't know anything.
And here again,
simply feeling grateful encourages
people to be more prosocial,
to suppress their own desires for self
interest and self profit in favor of
larger communal gain.
And if you look at actually how this
plays out in terms of people's emotions,
it's a pretty
straightforward relationship.
The more gratitude you feel,
the more you actually give
in a fairly linear fashion.
Now we've done this again with other
things that aren't monetarily based.
We've done it with requests for
help. And so in this case, uh,
we have a situation where individuals
feel gratitude and they are given the
option to help a complete stranger.
So they leave our experiment after they're
feeling grateful and they're walking
down the hall and someone
asks them for help.
And you can see here this
is the time spent helping.
They will help an individual significantly
more if they're feeling grateful.
But the reason we know it's gratitude
as if before they leave the lab,
we say to them, hey, the
other person in there,
they helped you in your computer
broke, right? And they'll say, yes,
that person did help me.
A,
what we're doing is we're binding the
feeling of gratitude toward that person.
They can't miss a tribute to someone else.
And then when someone
else asks them for help,
they don't help any more than they
would if in fact they weren't feeling
grateful at all. And that's how you know
it's not a pay it forward. You know,
it's not that I am,
I'm helping this person
because someone just helped me.
When we remind you that someone helped
you and remind you who you should feel
grateful toward,
you don't help anybody else.
But when you're just feeling grateful,
you could miss a tribute to that to a
new person and thereby help them as well.
And so we know it's an emotion based
effect. Let me give you one more example.
This is compassion.
Now,
compassion is a really interesting thing
to study because the world is full of
more people who need help than
we can possibly help, right?
If we tried to feel
compassion for everyone,
it would be impossible and overwhelming.
And so the question is out of all the
people in the world who need help,
how do we decide who it is
most beneficial to help?
Who is worthy of compassion?
And what I want to suggest is the way
we do this again is based on this trade
off between long term and
short term mechanisms.
And I'm going to show you how our
emotions help us solve this problem.
Short term, it makes no sense for me to
help anybody. It's going to cost me money,
time, effort, some type of
resources to help someone.
But long term if I help them then when
I need help they're more likely to help
me.
And so the question is which
way is the scale gonna go?
Who among the people who need help are
going to be the ones that I choose to
help and what are the longterm
is going to push me to do?
How are they going to determine what
compassion I feel and what I want to
suggest.
He was one way that we go about deciding
whether or not we should help someone
or whether or not we should feel
compassionate toward them is by a simple
analysis.
And that is do we see ourselves in them?
And so I want to suggest that one way
compassion works is it's based on a simple
metric and that metric is similarity.
The idea is the more
similar someone is to me,
the more compassion I will feel for them
even though they're suffering the same
objective. Uh, tragedy
as is another individual.
And what this suggests is that distress
is really in the eye of the beholder.
How much compassion I feel for someone
isn't a function of befallen them.
It's an a, it's a function
of their links to me. Now,
if I said to you on the battlefield in
American soldier comes upon a wounded
member of the Taliban and,
and wounded American soldiers and they
feel more compassion for the American
soldier,
that might not be surprising to you.
Those groups were in a
conflict for a long time,
but what I want to suggest to you is that
this bias is so deeply embedded in the
mind that we can see it with
the subtlest of cues and said,
the cue I really want to look at stripping
it down to bare bones is simple motor
synchrony, right? Moving in time together.
If you move your body in time
together, it's a marker of that. Now,
the, for this moment to individuals
or one they're purposes are joined,
their goals are joined and those are
the individuals who longterm are most
likely going to help me.
So how do we do this?
We bring individuals into lab and we sit
them down at a table across from each
other and they put on earphones.
They think they're in a music perception
study and their goal is simple.
Tap your hands to the tones you hear.
The only difference is sometimes
they tap their hands in unison.
Sometimes the tones are random,
so they're tapping and it completely
asynchronous way. They don't talk,
they don't do anything else.
What happens next is you see the
partner who you were tapping with,
engage in another experiment
that you're observing where uh,
he or she is cheated by another subject
and get stuck doing this onerous,
tedious task.
And then simply what we
do is we ask people, um,
if they want to help this person or not.
Now we don't ask them as experimenters
because there might be pressure there at
the end of the experiment that
computer simply says to them,
there's a lot of work to be done.
If for some reason that you'd
like to help somebody else,
please find the experimenters and
let them know. And what we found,
I have to admit to you is
rather astounding to me.
The simple act of tapping
your hands in time,
make people feel more
similar to each other.
Now they couldn't tell us
why they were more similar.
They would create stories about
They didn't even talk to the person,
but yet they felt more similar.
And what that similarity did is it gave
the longterm mechanisms of the mind
greater power to increase the
compassionate Rio in the field.
To make us help these individuals.
Because out of the two,
those individuals were more likely the
ones who would benefit us in the longterm.
And so here you can see the amount of
compassion they felt was also influenced
by whether they are not, they tap their
hands and time. Remember in each case,
the person is victimized in the same way
and is cheated in exactly the same way,
but how much compassion we feel for them
is a function of how similar we feel to
them. Moreover, if you look
at the decisions to help,
there's a really large difference,
right?
17 out of 35 people decided to help an
individual with whom they tap their hands
in time.
Only six out of 34 decided to do that in
cases where there was less similarity.
And if you look at the time they spent
helping, it's even more dramatic, right?
If I felt similar to you,
I helped you for much,
much longer than I did. If I felt
that you and I, we're not similar.
Now, the interesting thing about
this is if you look at how the,
the variables are linked, um, yes,
if I tap,
if you tapped your hands in time with me,
I felt more similar to
you and I liked you more.
But how much I liked you didn't predict
how much compassion I felt for you.
It didn't predict how much I helped you.
Similarity did.
And there's where you can see the trade
off between short term and long term.
And again, the more compassion I felt,
the more effort I engaged in to help you,
which longterm with
cement those social bonds.
And so what these data and findings
like them suggest is that yes,
human character,
human morality is flexible,
but it's not only the case that the
way we solve these problems of longterm
versus short term trade offs
is to suppress our emotions.
Rather as if we cultivate these emotions,
these social emotions,
things like gratitude,
things like compassion.
They will push us to act a
virtuous to cement social bonds,
to act in ways that raise all boats
as opposed to giving one person to
asymmetric profit.
And they will do so in a way that doesn't
require willpower because willpower
can fail.
And what it suggests is that the way
to navigate our social landscape most
successfully is really,
at least in terms of a
psychological mechanisms,
is to find the right balance
between short term and longterm.
It was Aristotle who said that virtue
is to be found between the two vices,
the vice, that's selfishness
and the vice of selflessness.
One can be too selfless,
at least biologically speaking.
And what our social emotions do are they
help push us as a countervailing wait
to selfishness to act in ways that builds
social capital and cement our social
bonds.
And thank you for your attention.
Thank you Dr. David Desteno for
just stay fabulous guest lecturer.
That made us all think a bit more about
what our social emotions and what role
do they play in shaping us to be not
too selfish but not too selfless either.
So what I want to turn to now,
our takeaway questions,
and these are going to be some of the
major take home points for you to ponder.
After you heard our very special
guest lecture today. So for today,
our take home questions are as follows.
So the first question says, what is
the pro social function of gratitude?
How can gratitude be experimentally
induced and what are the associated
behavioral tendencies?
Second,
what is the social function of
compassion and how can compassion affect
perceived similarity and helping?
So some of the experimental data that
Dr Desteno spoke about just recently.
And then finally,
this was sort of a interesting take home
point that was talked about it both the
beginning and end of his guest lecture.
To what extent do social emotions tell
us something about our moral character
and about the different vices that
he talked about of trying to be both,
you know,
selfish but not too selfish and
selfless but not too selfless.
And so with that, I want to turn
now to our expert interview.
This is part of our experts in emotion
interview series today for our experts
and emotion interview. We
have Dr. David Desteno. Um,
he'll be speaking with us on
emotions and social interaction.
So Dr Desteno received his phd in
psychology from Yale University and is
currently a professor of psychology at
northeastern university where he directs
the social emotions lab
at the broadest level.
His lab examines the mechanisms of the
mind that shape social behavior from
hypocrisy to compassion,
from pride to prejudiced, and
from honesty to punishment.
His work continuously reveals that human
moral behavior is much more variable
than most people would predict.
Dr distended was a fellow of the
association for Psychological Science and
editor of the American Psychological
Association sternal emotion.
His work has been repeatedly funded
by the National Science Foundation,
and he has been regularly featured in
the media, including the New York Times,
Newsweek, CBS, Sunday morning and
PR, and the Wall Street Journal.
He's also the coauthor of the Wall Street
Journal psychology bestseller out of
character,
and as written about his research for
the New York Times and Boston Globe.
So I now turn with excitement to our
experts and emotion interview with Dr.
David Desteno.